[Music]  Arcadia is a hotbed for supernatural  activity there's a whole other world we  know nothing about creatures living  shadows monsters living amongst us  whenever they are someone or something  in Arcadia is at the center of this oh  my gosh is this a call like a a good old  traditional be really doing this I think  we are but I was only half listening and  he was talking really fast  it cannot be death would be on every  Boston Arcadia was turned to ash we're  gonna have to stop  if only I had a portable Warhammer oh  wait I do  [Music]  [Music]  the amulet made you a troll  you made yourself a hero  [Music]  ah our breakfast burrito  [Music]